and other subjects, CNN senior
political analyst John avlon and
CNN political commentator
Margaret Hoover, host of pbs
firing line, John, you know,
more than one pundit has
proclaimed that the NRA's
influence in the GOP is waning.
I mean, that's been a storyline
for a few years now, but how can
that be the case if all of these
presidential hopefuls are
flocking to be part of this
convention? It's not the case
when it comes to their influence
over the base. It is the case
that the area is severely
weakened and diminished
organization because of the
scandals, financial and
otherwise that have have emerged
in recent years and weekend, the
organization leadership Wayne
Lapierre, and cause a lot of
defections from their board. But
you still see these presidential
candidates go to kiss the ring
because at this stage it's very
much about appealing to the base
and particularly when it comes
to the second amendment voters,
NRA is still most powerful lobby
that there there is. And
Margaret. I mean, there were
some very various different
reactions will just put it that
way for the speakers. Let's
start with what happened when
former vice president Mike pence
greeted the crowd. Let's listen
to that. I love you, too. I hope
you gave pence a good warm.
Approval. He could not because
he is a he is a nice man. If you
want to really know the truth,
he is. He's a good man. And I
heard it was very rough.
Margaret what is your sense of
that? I mean, how is Mike pence
going to win the Republican
nomination when he's getting
booed? At an NRA convention like
that. I mean, what you see is
that the NRA convention like
John reference. You know it is
message. It is part of the base
of the Republican party. It's a
specific, you know, fashion of
the base of the Republican
party, which is trump base there
is, you know, Mike pence's team
would argue a deeply evangelical
, uh, observant Christian base
of the party that is more likely
to be sympathetic to Mike pence
as a candidate. That's at least
what they're planning on. But
the N R a yeah, even though it
is waiting. I mean, most NRA
members, as we know, are even
for reasonable restrictions in
gun control and gun reforms.
Right, therefore, background
checks. There are four um,
safety checks there. You know,
there are moderate. Republicans
and NRA members who are
absolutely for moving this
debate forward, but it is become
special interest of the
Republican party that is
beholden to the base, and so it
no longer functions as an issue
out of the organization as much
as a arm of the Republican party
. And if I could just add,
though, there's a particularly
irony for group that says it's
all about defending the
constitution attack booing of
vice president who did more than
any other individual in January,
6th to defend the constitution.
Let's not forget that but I
guess you know I can hear their
folks that I have to imagine.
There are folks at home who are
frustrated about all of this
given what took place in
Nashville, given what took place
in Louisville. That we just
can't get to a place where any
kind of, you know real
meaningful gun control
legislation can get past this
country. And it does seem as
though when you have major
presidential candidates at the
NRA. That that that is, that is
the main stumbling block. Save
Jim. I mean, that's absolutely
true when it comes to gun
reform. It's absolutely true
when it comes to reasonable
restrictions around abortion.
It's absolutely true when it
comes to questions of climate
control, so if you are an issue
climate change if you are an
issue advocacy voter, if there's
an issue that is important to
you, maybe what you ought to
look at is the kind of election
reforms that are going to deep
polarized the country and start
representing Americans and not a
narrow faction of a base of one.
One political party. Yeah and
John this afternoon, Georgia's
governor, Brian Kemp, is urging
fellow Republicans to move on
from election fraud claims CNN
obtained a copy of remarks can
prepared for private RNC donor
retreat. He doesn't really name
trump camp, says 2020 is ancient
history, not a single swing
voter and a single swing state
will vote for our nominee if
they choose to talk about the
2020 election being stolen. I
mean, I guess you know, he
points for you know, he is
saying in a roundabout way he's
not going after trump by name,
though. But how significant is
that? Look I kept deserves a lot
of credibility for not going
around with along with this
nonsense in the wake of the
election in the first place. Now
he's decided, you know, he said
he himself the speculation he
might run, but I don't
understand why these folks who
are condemning, you know of this
obsession with election lies,
too, too, too afraid to name
names. It's not like people
aren't aware of what they're
saying. There's this tiptoeing
around, even in Chris Christie,
uh, indulging this kind of
thing. Just call it what it is a
lie and the person who is
properly gating it more than any
other human being. Donald Trump.
Full stop. That's courage. And
we just haven't seen any of
that. But John Margaret, hang
on. I know we don't do this very
often during the segments, but I
want you to stand by because we
actually do have some news
coming into CNN. This just in
the scene a big turn about at
Fox News. The right wing channel
has formally apologize to the
judge overseeing the dominion
voting systems lawsuit against
the network and a letter which
was dated Friday and filed with
the court. Fox attorney Blake
Rohrabacher said the network
never intended to mislead about
owner Rupert Murdoch's role at
the company that reads quote. We
understand the courts concerns
apologize and are committed to
clear and full communication
with the court moving forward,
the letter goes on to say we
should have provided to the
court a complete and private
response to the courts.
Questions concerning the
identities. Of all of Fox News
is officers. We apologize and
never intended to avoid
responding to a question from
the court on the phone right now
to explain our marshal Cohen,
who is covering the upcoming
trial marshal. This is
extraordinary. Fox News does not
apologize very often. Jim it's
an apology directly to the judge
after they got scolded
repeatedly in court. Jim this is
all about Rupert Murdoch and his
role not just at the parent
company, fox corporation, but
also Fox News for years in this
litigation, fox said that
Murdoch was only involved the
parent company and not involved
at Fox News. Dominion says that
that this prohibited them from
getting access to more of
Murdoch's documents, emails,
phone logs, other material that
it wanted to get in the
discovery process. It came out
just about a week ago that fox
News those representations that
it had been making that Murdoch
did not have a role at Fox News
at the network that he actually
did. He was an executive officer
there, and the judge was not
happy because the judge had been
told by fox multiple times that
he had no role at the company.
It's very legal. It's very
complicated, but the bottom line
here was this whole sort of keep
away hide the ball situation
really upset the judge so much
so that he decided to bring in a
special master. A third party, a
Turkey attorney to investigate
fox to look into the possibility
that they may have intentionally
lied to the court. And withheld
evidence. And in this new letter
, Jim boxes clearly saying they
didn't lie. It was a
misunderstanding. And they are
very, very sorry, but all of
this is happening on the eve of
trial. We're just a day away.
Monday morning is when we're
expecting things to reconvene in
Remington with the end of jury
selection and the beginning of
opening statement, so on the eve
of trial, a mere Copa from fox
News. Wow that is a big
development. Art marshal Cohen.
Thank you very much. Let me get
back to John Avalon and Margaret
Hoover. Uh sorry. Part of the
interruption as they say, guys,
but I mean this case this this
dominion case against fox. Um I
was. I'm blown away by the fact
that the fox actually apologized
for something that does not
happen very often. But to have
this sort of thing happened in
the in the case in the courtroom
with the judge going after the
right before this trial gets
started. That cannot be good.
No. Uh, let me just say you're
right. Fox is not inclined to
apologize to their viewers to
their hosts to the victims of
sexual, uh, assault or
intimidation, but they're going
to apologize to a judge because
they have a $1.2 billion
judgment in front of them. If
you're going to tell the truth
to anyone, it's somebody who
really hold your faith because
there's not just this lawsuit.
There are future lawsuits. And
so I think it is telling. Ah but
I think it's also different than
owning responsibility and moral
responsibility for the havoc
they have reached on the public.
Well, putting that aside the
idea that this was some
misunderstanding. They're trying
to clear up his totally
disingenuous. This has been an
institutionalized
misunderstanding. It's big news
that on the eve of them finally
going to trial they're trying to
do to prevent defense and clean
up for the judge court. No, but
I mean, you know they're they're
trying to clean things up. And
sort of, you know, say it was
all all a terrible
misunderstanding. No. I mean
what the reality is they're
about to enter. As a CNN
headline said the other day, the
real no spin zone, which is
court and they're not gonna get
away with the kind of lies and